- That's a weird question.
- Oh, this is a too weird question.
- Is this a trick question?
- Damn, where the hell'd you
come up with this question?
- Can I ask you a question about it?
- [Thoraya] Yeah, sure.
- Is that assuming that
it's missing within me?
- [Thoraya] However
you wanna interpret it?
- Oh.
- [Thoraya] It's up to you.
- I miss most about myself,
even though I do it every day,
is smiling and laughing.
I always love how that feels.
I realized it when I went
through a bad breakup.
And towards the end of the relationship
I realized I wasn't smiling a lot.
And when I went through the breakup,
certain things started to uplift me
as I get more into myself,
and learned myself,
and learned to love myself again.
And I started to realize at some point
my cheeks hurt, like I'm smiling a lot.
And I used to feel so shy
about it at the beginning,
I was like, oh, am I, why
am I the only one smiling?
Am I the only one feeling like this?
And I realized it didn't
matter if I was or wasn't,
because even I was,
if someone else could feel
it they'll feel like it too.
So, it just felt good
to feel and go through.
But I went through a
period of not feeling it
for a long time before I realized that.
So, I guess I had to be
without appreciate it more.
(gentle music)
- I miss being so naive and innocent.
I miss thinking like a child.
I have so much knowledge
now about the world,
that I just miss being like,
like innocent and stupid, not
know nothing about the world.
'Cause it's a really harsh
world that we live in today.
- I miss the way I was
before I knew that depression overtook me
and before I started like
purposely hurting myself,
because I thought that things were normal
and I felt happier and more innocent.
I dunno, I think it
was slightly over time,
but I did have like a few triggers,
like getting bullied and just like,
I also have struggled
with an eating disorder
and that just like
really degraded my brain
and the way that I thought of things.
And I feel like one day I just
gave up on life completely.
- Probably when I was little
and I wouldn't care what others
would think, like about me.
But like, as we get older,
we realize what the standards
that society puts for one.
Well, I've always been like a bigger kid.
And when I was little,
I wouldn't care when
people would like call me,
you know, big, fat, whatever,
'cause I would just like let it slide.
But, when we get older,
we kind of realize like
the meaning behind that.
Yeah.
(gentle music)
- So, I'm slowly starting to
get this part of myself back,
but I miss being happy.
I was very unhappy for a long time
dealing with a lot of disrespect
in the relationship that I was in.
And I finally left that and it's,
I'm learning to be myself again.
Which is a whole new self
because I was with this
person for 11 years.
So, it's been a learning process
and I'm honestly enjoying
getting to know myself
'cause I'm learning I'm
really awesome. (laughing)
And I don't know, it's, I'm
learning to be happy again.
And that's something that's
really, really important
because, I don't know, I
wasn't happy for a long time,
so I'm really happy that
I'm getting that back.
- I miss knowing myself.
So, I was also in a ten year relationship.
And you do become one.
And so I was, I was interested in things,
and watching things, and reading
things, and eating things
that I realized like
weren't even my choices.
So, in the last few months I'm learning
what do I actually like?
Who am I? What do I enjoy?
Figured out that I like
eating an early dinner,
but something I haven't done in 10 years.
I really like, like a five o'clock dinner,
but I was used to a 10 o'clock.
So, that's nice.
I like traveling with my
friends only. (laughing)
Yeah. So I, I miss myself,
because I feel like I gave up on myself.
- [Thoraya] Was it like an
ah-ha moment? (indistinct)
- Yeah, actually,
when I discovered that
I like early dinners.
And I know that sounds so silly
and like such a weird thing to say,
but once I started living without him
I started paying attention to myself.
Like actually paying attention
to me. What do I want?
And I'm like, oh, I'm, I'm hungry.
It's 5:00 PM. It's still daylight.
I'm hungry. I made myself dinner.
I sat down and I ate it,
and I was so satisfied.
And then it hit me like I
haven't done this in years
and I cried.
You know, that sounds so silly.
but I cried at the fact that I
got to eat dinner at 5:00 PM,
when I was hungry.
And I wasn't concerned about
anybody else. I was hungry.
- Uh, I miss when I
was more compassionate.
When I was younger, I
was very, very caring
and very trusting, trusting person.
Then I got near some people
who wasn't really, really, for me.
They would only be cool when
it was convenient for them.
And I thought making myself more reserved
would solve that problem,
but I still feel the same.
Ever since I had my
daughter, I've softened up
and I've like learned
to let people more in
than I would like to, but it's a process.
(gentle music)
- I think I miss the confidence
I had when I was younger.
- I miss the confidence
that I used to have.
- I miss my confidence.
- [Thoraya] What made you lose that?
- Trauma. The world.
I guess I lost my ability to be confident
because of how other
people are in the world,
their judgments, their,
the harm that they cause.
- So, I have clinical
depression, and I have anxiety,
and I have cyclothymia,
which is a bipolar disorder.
And I miss feeling okay.
I, you know, I was talking
about it with a friend
and sometimes I wake up
and I'm like I don't, I
don't wanna do anything.
Like, I don't want to get out of bed.
I miss feeling like myself,
'cause I used to be this
like very bubbly person.
And right now I feel like
I'm just like faking it till I make it.
Which, you know,
it's probably not the
best coping mechanism,
but I do go to therapy
and I go with my psychiatrist every month.
And so I miss feeling okay
and feeling comfortable
with being vulnerable.
- I would say my depression,
whenever, you know, at a young age
trauma and all that good stuff happens.
And then when you get
around to finally fixing it
you don't really realize who you are.
So, it's fun learning about yourself,
but I gotta say, I do miss it.
My favorite spice blend that I made
was one that I made while
in a bad mental breakdown.
And I, I kinda miss that
'cause that means I won't be able to make
that type of a spice
blend again. (laughing)
That was a weird answer. But, yeah.
- [Thoraya] So, you
miss having depression?
- Being motivated to do things
that other people want me to do.
I used to kind of thrive
on the thought of people being proud of me
for doing things like school.
But I, it's, it's not really
that I don't care anymore,
it's just like, like
I, I feel so burnt out
that that doesn't really,
that's not something that
strikes me as important anymore.
Yeah. That's it.
- I think I miss the excitement
of getting up in the morning for game day.
I've been a basketball my entire life,
and that's always kind
of been my identity.
And it wasn't until probably high school
that I fell out of love with the game.
Something that I really miss
is just
being excited to play a game
that I love without any pressure,
without any expectation.
Being from where I'm from,
there's not a lot of kids
that get out of my situation
from where I grew up.
And so I felt like I
always had a responsibility
to play basketball, earn a scholarship,
go to school, and make
something of myself.
- I think I miss being able
to fight things head on.
I think I got a little bit too soft.
I used to be real strong in
the way I advocated for myself.
And now I'm a little bit too forgiving.
- [Thoraya] What made you lose that?
- Wanting certain people in my life.
- I think that it is sort
of restoring my faith.
I think I lost sight of it. I
don't know if I'm losing it.
Yeah, I mean, I dunno how
to describe it, I guess.
And, you know, like the component
of just not feeling guilty.
I think that's, to me, yeah.
Yeah, it's like I get it,
but I think I can reach
the same levels of goodness
by not being held
accountable to that extent.
You know what I mean?
Like I know it was
getting really technical,
but religion, I guess,
is the way I see that.
But, yeah, I think overall is
just continue to explore it.
You know, like thinking
about getting back to it,
just like continue to explore it
until you get some sort of concise answer.
- Hm.
Having my, all my brains. Doing things.
I can't do stuff anymore
now. I'm 66 years old.
I can't do anything, so that bothers me.
But when I was young, I was a spitfire.
I skydived, I rock climbed, I repelled,
I rode the rapids,
I've been in the ocean, I flew a plane.
I've been in the Army.
I can't do 'em anymore.
I can't do none of those things.
My memory's not good right now anymore.
See, it's a lot of things.
I'm a mess, but I'm fighting it all.
So, I'm not too happy to, you
know, to die anytime soon.
But when it comes, I'm ready. Yeah.
- [Thoraya] Well, thank you
for answering my questions.
- You're welcome hon.
- [Narrator] I appreciate you.
- You're welcome.
- Hey everyone.
For those of you who are
new, my name is Thoraya,
and I'm the girl behind the camera.
Make sure to subscribe and
hit the notification bell
so you'll be notified every
time I have a new episode up.
And follow me on Instagram.
I'll be posting more on there.
As always, thank you guys for everything.
I love you all, and
I'll see you next time.
(gentle music)